le procès important est assez surprenant
vient de connaître son dénouement
aujourd'hui à new york
grosse houle brique un jeune internaute
de 30 ans qui était accusé d'être à la
tête du site web silkroad qu'on a
surnommé le hib et de la drogue a été
reconnu coupable de sept chefs
d'accusation dont blanchiment d'argent
et trafic de drogue
ça se passait dans un des recoins peu
connue de la toile qu'on appelle le web
sombre ou dark web
bonsoir mathieu et sa cellule d'abord
commençons par dire ce qu'est le web
sombre il faut comprendre si on fait la
métaphore du web comme un océan que le
web auxquelles on a accès avec nos
navigateurs c'est la surface de la
science et 10 % seulement de cet océan
là est en dessous de ça on retrouve le
web profond qu est-ce que c'est le wave
profonde est tout simplement des pages
qui ne sont pas indexés par les
navigateurs comme par exemple lorsqu'on
voit sur notre compte devant ce que vous
allez sur le ton de banque vous allez
sur le web profond alors heureusement
que c'est pas indexer et en dessous de
ça on retrouve le web sombre alors ça
c'est la partie du rêve vraiment la plus
difficile à laquelle on peut avoir accès
justement comment est ce qu'on y
accèdent ironiquement c'est par un
instrument qui a été développé par
l'armée américaine
c'est un réseau qui s'appelle de thor
ter qui est l'acronyme de dix ans nous
tuons entre repas dans les détails
ça donne un internaute qui utilisent
soit une anomie un anonymat presque
parfait et c'est grâce à ce que put
mener sa barque pendant presque deux ans
plus de deux ans de février 2011 jusqu'à
octobre 2013 date de son arrestation
et qu'est-ce qu'on pouvait acheter une
autre sur ceux ci en grande partie de la
drogue évidemment et c'est pour ça qu'il
a été reconnu coupable entre autres
choses mais aussi des choses légales
comme par exemple des livres ou encore
du matériel érotique et contrairement à
ce que bien des gens ont voulu laisser
entendre on ne retrouvait pas sur de
cette fraude du matériel de pornographie
infantile ou encore des armes est donc
l'enjeu de ce procès était important là
absolument parce que il faut comprendre
que ça s'inscrit dans un climat beaucoup
plus large où les accès ou les outils de
cryptographie sont beaucoup plus
facilement accessible et la manière de
la vie
de manière anonyme sur le web aussi
c'est plus facile on l'exemple avec ce
réseau l'auteur est extrêmement
difficile d'aller chercher
d'informations sur ce jeu noble donc
lise autorités en place veulent frapper
un grand coup dans l'imaginaire
populaire est associé le fait qu'on
navigue de manière anonyme sur le web à
quelque chose de mal
et d'ailleurs si les déficits de
françois de sombres et d'ailleurs les
défenseurs de la vie privée sur le web
s'en défend bien ils disent c'est pas
parce qu'on veut naviguer de manière
anonyme sur le web c'est pas parce qu'on
utilise des outils de cryptographie
qu'on veut nécessairement faire de
mauvaises choses et ils disent aux gens
qui disent moi j'ai rien à cacher alors
j'utilise le web normal leur disait à ce
moment là donnez nous dont vous tous vos
mots de passe de décide que vous
utilisez alors c'est un grand débat
il y suit donc de ça parce que le
jugement sera rendu la sentence sera
rendue au moins 2006 opa appel au mois
d'avril
c'est très intéressant à suivre parce
qu'il aura énormément de suite à ce
procès sur le web et dans la vraie vie
lui il risque gros la 30 ans peut-être
la prison à vie
donc c'est des accusations très graves
qui pèsent contre lui merci beaucoup aux
plaisirs mathieu